what is broken britain facing a summer
of discontent that is union to ballot
for industrial action as a communication
workers union tomorrow 115 000 postal
workers at royal mail will vote whether
or not to strike over pay with the
result due in mid july as well as
posties threatening to down their
mailbags the cwu represents 45 000
workers at british telecom so the strike
does go ahead well good luck to the
millions of bt customers trying to get
the wi-fi to work bad enough as it is
well the ballot follows last week's rail
strikes and a plan walk out by british
airways baggage handlers and joining me
now is the general secretary of the
communication workers union dave ward
dave thank you for coming in first of
all appreciate that very much i start
most interviews with union workers by
going straight to your
facebook profile page of after mick
lynch and the hood went viral and when i
went to yours today dave ward after a
little bit of prompting from me on
twitter i discovered this
have we got it
there we are this is your and that is
your
little joke at my expense where you said
i was taking part in a i think what did
you call it unofficial walkout an
unofficial cat stream an unofficial
wildcat strike which is when i left good
morning britain now they're calling you
wild cat morgan now well i actually
quite like the title um rather like mitt
lynch likes being called the hood all i
would say about that was yes i did walk
out in my little bit of industrial
wildcat action but ten minutes later i
came back to work without a penny pay
rise i went back to my workstation now
albeit i did all falling out with my
employers later in the day and did
indeed leave my job but actually my
strike lasted 10 minutes and i realized
that my strike was going to cause huge
disruption and distress to the british
public and so i saw the light and came
back
dave
well i mean what i'd say to that is that
the objective of any dispute when you
ballot your members for industrial
action um it's always because there's
been events that have taken place
negotiations
um and you then balance and you know we
have a right to do that under the law
um and the objective is never to ever
strike pits you know i mean disputes are
about settlements but sometimes
if you get the right mandate and you
can't go any further with negotiations
and we'll give all of those companies
that you're talking about the
opportunity to have further negotiations
before we serve any notice
of strike action uh that's if we
obviously get the the right results um
which i'm confident that we will
um you know we we want settlements but
here's my problem
and my problem is not with your workers
right because i thought in the pandemic
the postal workers were magnificent
magnificent i speak from personal
experience the guys that were
serving me in my neighborhood
unbelievable they were every day through
the pandemic they were working far
harder than normal because there were so
many more deliveries being made people
were at home in lockdown so i have great
admiration for postal workers let's put
that on the table right now nothing
wrong actually with trades unions or you
fighting for your workers here's my
problem this country right now like many
countries in the world for every country
in the world is suffering huge economic
strife we know this we're on the
precipice of being tipped into a
recession possibly worse and right now
we have obviously the rail strike action
british airways now you guys threatening
it uh london underground ryanair easyjet
nhs teachers barristers uh bus drivers
rail workers british airways and so on
there's a whole raft now of threats or
actual strikes of threats going on
and the consequence of this
is that if we're not very careful we are
going to tip ourselves not just into a
recession but potentially another great
depression and my question for you as a
union leader is
do you care about that do you care i
mean
how do you put a premium on individual
workers if it was left to you given
inflation is raging at 11
would you like every worker in the
country to get an 11 pay rise to cover
inflation
look i think there's a a lot of points
you've raised there and let me answer
all of them really i mean the first
thing i would say is that our message is
every worker counts
so you know we're not saying we're
special although i agree with you and i
think postal workers will welcome what
you said about the contribution they
made during the pandemic because there's
no doubt about it they were fantastic no
doubt and often overlooked um in very
difficult circumstances there's also a
way
can i just say they were also dealing
with at the same time as the problems
with the pandemic they were dealing with
a hell of a lot of change at that time
and so every worker counts from where
we're seeing um and the background to
this dispute this is not a dispute about
affordability you know royal mao have
made literally on the backs of their
staff record profits of 758 million
pounds they chose to pay 400 million
pounds to the shareholders and at the
same time as the ceo
received the bonus of 140 000 pounds
they decided to impose a 2 pay rise on
the workforce that's a big mistake how
much do you get how much do you get paid
i get paid a hundred and seven thousand
pounds it's a hell of a lot of money
right there is a difference let me just
explain that well i work out the cat can
be middling fat or very fat or extremely
fat or i'm fairly fat like my point
being i'm not you know i'm not i'm not
going to graduate
so
are you worth any more or less than a
boss of these companies well that's for
our members to determine what do you
think because well i'm going to tell you
the circumstances we're a democratic
organization i get elected every five
years and so it's not a permanent job in
that sense and every year we send out
financial report that's got all the
salaries of our officers and our
organization can debate that every year
and branches reps and members can come
there and change that if they don't
think that's right and i'm sure that you
know if we have that debate we'll have
to live with whatever the outcome of
that is compare that to some of the
people who are the real fat cats who are
on something like 30 or 40 times uh the
their workforce in terms of is that a
salary number you gave me is that the
exact one or is that after you've
deducted taxes well it's the salary as i
know it's salary what's the total
package that's gross that's great what's
your total package my total package i
don't look at the national insurance 143
thousand it's probably around that a few
weeks
i mean here's my point but you're taking
pension contributions i understand a
national insurance company
i'm not my salary
and seven thousand pounds your package
is a hundred and forty three thousand
right i'm not begrudgingly would you ask
me the question well because a lot of
the union leaders are running around
going these fat cat bosses and i'm like
a lot of people watching this who are
really on the breadling be like well
what about you lot you're all on 100
i was a postal worker for many many
years right and i accept completely what
were you earning then i was probably
earning about 20 well there you go so
you're earning look i'm not that's not
i'm not here so you're only seven
members you're only seven
let ceos put up their salaries and let
members vote on that
i am not begrudging you your money i'm
just saying when you spray around the
word fat cats as the union bosses are
doing a lot of them are pretty fat
themselves when it comes to service
certainly a lot fatter than their
employees can i say something one of the
problems
i'm not suggesting by any stretch that
i'm facing the same issues that all of
our members are on the current cost of
living so he's targeting the bosses over
their pay fare given that you're pretty
well paid yourself of course it's fair
because we're
not anywhere near in that league
and you know these are people who i
don't think are growing businesses
anymore i think there was a time many
many years back where people might have
argued that a good bus you know grows a
business and you wouldn't worry too much
about what they got that's not what's
happening in the uk today these are
people who are hitting numbers and they
don't care what the impact is how much
have you been offered by raw mail so far
they say they say five and a half
percent let me say what's actually
happened uh there was a two percent
increase that's been imposed
uh so we rejected is it true they've
offered up to five what they what they
offered linked to change was another
three and a half percent uh linked to
unacceptable change which we're never
going to agree but i would say it's okay
but i would say to you there are debates
to be had about by the way they've now
agreed yeah when they imposed the two
percent they've now agreed to treat
change separately okay and there are
separate talks going on okay but say for
arguments that you end up at four or
five percent right
would that be acceptable to you no i
don't think it would be acceptable at
the moment because inflation's running
uh 11 percent but here's my point
if we accept
them sort of pay offers and that's not
on the table
um you know i have to say that our
members pay will be permanently eroded
but here's my problem with this whole
issue like i said at the start the first
question about all this if everybody
wants a pay rise for their workers in
line with inflation this country goes
bust you accept that right
no what i actually think you're saying
in that sense is that you know do you
really expect to get everybody up to
that level well that's a matter for
negotiation we're not silly people we
will know what a good deal is at the top
if everyone is getting pay rises right
now
about the country
going going bust
i think we need to have a proper
discussion in this country about the
main issue that's at the heart of every
injustice you see and the common
denominator is this is it doesn't matter
whether it's the financial crisis in
2008 whether it's the pandemic whether
it's a climate crisis or a cost of
living crisis the rich and the powerful
are getting richer and more powerful and
working people are paying the price i
don't disagree with it so what we're
going to do about it well we have to do
something i think that is a i think by
the way on on this higher than inflation
yeah i don't think there's enough focus
on how these companies
who i know for a fact two companies
there bt and royal mail put their prices
up uh by about 10 earlier this year when
inflation was running about 5
and they are creating some of the
spiraling and inflation and i'll tell
you why to protect their profit margins
and also to feed into some of the stuff
i think you raised
i think like a lot of the union leaders
mick lynch included i think you're all
raising a lot of valid points right
there's no question my issue with the
problem right now is the country is an
economic meltdown and if actually all
these strikes happen we have a terrible
summer of massive discontent we will tip
ourselves into a really serious possibly
in the short term irrevocable financial
crisis which might cause immeasurably
more harm than anything we're even
seeing now and i think you guys probably
know that and you must you must be
starting to feel a little bit uneasy but
if everyone goes out on strike and
everybody wants pay rises what happens
to this country well look we're not a
point where everyone's gone on strike
i believe all workers deserve higher pay
in the current circumstances it's a
matter for their individual unions um to
deal with that and i'll repeat what i
said earlier on no there'll be
settlements if the companies that employ
these workers actually start putting
decent offers on the table now that's a
matter for negotiation so i think the
circumstances you're talking about
are unlikely to happen and but i would
say to you that i do think it's time for
a serious change in the uk about the
whole way that we think about the world
of work the way that the economy is
rigged against working people um and
including that you know the injustices
and inequalities that are growing in
society okay you know we've got to do
something about you know dave i don't
disagree with you and i think working
practice is changing join our union
people well i support unions i i don't
see that but i don't respond responsible
unions behaving responsibly on behalf of
their workers i'm just worried at the
moment about the greater bigger picture
for the country this country cannot
afford to start giving everybody massive
pay rises and if everyone goes out on
strike without getting one we're going
to be looking
at do you accept that the country can't
afford the inequalities that are growing
at the moment so let's agree on that and
let's work forward on all those i agree
that some bosses get way too much money
out of kilter with their performance i
agree with what you just said and i
agree that you should be supporting your
workers as best you can but i don't want
to see everybody out on strike
well at least we're having a ballot you
just walked out and we're having a and
we're having a good conversation all
right and you came here mitch i
appreciate it dave good to see you thank
you very much
you